cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com we got the store out of the
Daily Mail Fool's Gold expert questions
whether Costco's
1945 dollar one ounce gold bars are
really a good deal as Shoppers rush to
snap them up amid rampant inflation and
bank failures I'm a gold bug so I say
yes so uh Costco started selling gold
bars customers can buy two per shopping
session or whatever you'd call it
and they sold out and uh what I heard
was people are buying them because
they're getting cash back on their
credit cards and that two percent that's
money you then sell it at a smaller loss
or something like you can sell it for a
one percent loss but you make two
percent off the credit cards that's what
people are doing but a lot of people are
just point flat out saying they want
gold right now because the economy is
going to implode so I don't whatever the
reason may be
when you hear that there's a run on gold
among regular people that's scary I'm
kind of worried about that it's not
mentioning no I gotta say I have silver
I have gold I have crypto I am not
worried in the sense that I will be done
harm because I already bought gold
I'm going to be worried about what the
other people are going to do when they
can't get any
yeah when yeah you know what I mean like
you can't get it it's like they're
running out there are there are other
things for that
well I'm not I I depending on the degree
of conflict this country faces depending
on how bad things get
people misunderstand what the value of
gold is the value of gold is a hard
asset that's not being replicated it's
it's hard to produce so it retains its
value
however Gold's been floating around this
the same price for quite a while it's
just like you know you if you're living
in the United States it's good to have
gold it's it's good to hedge your bets
against the US dollar all that stuff
because gold it's worth something right
but in the event of like a total social
breakdown
I got I'm sorry like what are you gonna
do with gold that was what I was
thinking too you're gonna bring your
gold your one ounce gold bar for two
grand to a burger shop and be like can
you make change meanwhile nobody's gonna
be at the Burger Shop no one will be
working at the Burger Shop no I mean I
think there will be uh just because
social order breaks down doesn't mean
there's not going to be business there's
so when there was a blackout in New York
City in 2003 uh and it was the like one
of the substations sort of blew up and
we could all see like the smoke coming
up and um and the you know all the
lights went out downtown and everyone's
like oh my God it's 9 11 except it's
2003 now and uh we're walking around I
had my paycheck because we all got
evacuated from our buildings there was
no lights on and I just very quietly
like took my paycheck out of the drawer
which eventually I got fired but um yeah
because I took my pay and I didn't give
anybody else their pay I was just like
I'm not leaving paydays tomorrow I have
all the checks I'm just taking mine
anyway but so what you couldn't get
McDonald's what no it wasn't that I
couldn't get McDonald's it was that I
had trouble cashing my check oh of
course so I went to a check cashing
place and there was a guy in the dark
with candles and a shotgun and he cashed
my check right and and people didn't
understand you look at videos out of
Syria during the Civil War and there are
people walking to and from work carrying
food and groceries people don't stop
living because conflict happens however
you're not going to carry a gold bar
into a McDonald's and be like y'all take
a number one uh supersize the fries and
give me a bunch of sweet and sour sauce
and here's one two thousand dollar gold
bar can you can you break that for me
they're gonna be like no yeah they might
be taking gold that's true silver coins
silver coins so if you uh so I'm not
gonna tell anybody what to buy but what
I would buy they have uh websites where
you can buy American silver coins like
actual dimes nickels quarters and bags
of them and they they like they actually
represent the silver value of them so if
you're if you're trading with something
but I gotta be honest man
when we started trading gold and silver
it was because it was hard enough to get
but easy enough to get silver like
aluminum was worth more than silver
it was just like is it real silver okay
we'll trade with it
basing the value of the currency on
silver it was what this is the same
thing it's it's no different than
putting a serial number on a dollar bill
basically letting you know it was real
in the event of an actual social
breakdown you know what's you know Phil
knows what's going to happen what are
you going to buy a cheeseburger with you
you want you want to buy a two number
ones for you and your girl and you go to
McDonald's what's the currency they're
going to take I can't say on YouTube
[Laughter]
yeah you can I'll say it it's bullets
yeah
but listen listen currently you can
still buy body armor night vision is
king oh get guns and ammo night vision
people really don't people need to know
this
there's two things that make the
Americans so dangerous air superiority
is number one and I could be wrong but
night vision is a major the night yep I
think night vision might be number two
the thing the thing people don't realize
that if if you if you want to you can
get night vision and you can equip stuff
so that way you have infrared lights on
your gear and you can see everything and
it is black as night for anyone that
doesn't have night vision
like absolutely no lights
that no one can see any light on you and
you are looking around like it's daytime
it's it's crazy it is I got and and real
night vision not the stuff you get on
like Amazon where it's like a camera
that just you know to be fair these
low-grade Bargain Bin hundred dollar
infrared cameras can help you see at
night so hey no beef better than nothing
legit military attack night vision well
where did you do something like that you
can get them tnv tnvc.com the what and
if you want to get the good military
ones they're PVS 31s they're dual tubes
you can see satellites yep no way you
look in the sky and you see satellites
and it's just like wow what does that go
for thirteen thousand dollars was the
one that I got fairly cost prohibitive
but maybe maybe once some other people
get there but you record seven gold bars
you can get you can get it you can get a
PVS 31 which is a single tube so the
mine mine are dual tubes but you can get
a single tube for somewhere around three
thousand dollars so it's like you know
it's expensive but it's something that
the average person can afford and just
one eye yeah one eye and and that is
still way better than nothing hunting
hunting it's great yeah it's crazy and
again and I'll say it again body armor
you can get you can still buy body armor
there are politicians that are looking
to make these things illegal yeah if you
can get it if you can get this stuff if
you can afford it it's not a bad idea to
get it now do you have a do you know
what frass is no it's uh I forgot what
companies uh Safe Life or something
flexible rifle armor system oh so it's
it's a hexagonal ceramic plates whereas
your typical ceramic plate can withstand
only one about one or two rounds
typically one they that's what they
train us on they say one round and
you're and if you get hit like your arm
is no good the ceramic stuff because
they're all separate plates they
actually can withstand a bit more still
you don't want to get shot so there's a
confidence avoiding those things there's
a company called Hesco that I that I uh
saw some stuff that has come back from
Ukraine recently uh they were
advertising and they were taken full 762
by 31 or 762 by 51 which is uh 308
rounds NATO uh big bullets very fast and
they're you know out they're defeating
armor is getting impressive armor is
impressive yeah it's crazy and again it
is available now and there are people
that want there are politicians that
want to make that stuff illegal so I'm
just I'm wondering uh the extent to
which people think the collapse is
happening right so obviously we talk
about Civil War but Civil War
we talk about this wide perspective
which could be it's a cultural battle
where people are being arrested in
prison so there is physical violence but
it's not like armies marching but maybe
the high-end extreme version of that is
it does get to like a total social
breakdown I don't know which way it goes
I'm wondering what the average person
thinks because these people who are
buying up this gold like crazy ain't
listening to this show some of them are
for sure but we're talking about Costco
selling out gold bars yeah that's way
bigger than anything we can do or yeah
so regular people are looking at
something and being like I Gotta Buy
Gold yeah
that's kind of worrying to me yep
confidence breaking down in the system I
bet it's the flash mobs they're all
Trump's getting arrested there's also
like a ton of gold advertising on
alternative media like real America's
voice recently yeah I feel like but
listen listen companies look at you look
at some of this like this this lady
right here on Tick Tock awareness no I
don't think this lady and I'm and I'm
and I'm not trying to be discriminatory
here based on what she looks like or
anything like that but I I would be
willing to bet it is not that likely
that she's listening to Infowars Tim
Cass Stephen Crowder or whatever whoever
else has got gold commercials Ben
Shapiro I have a really good friend who
I've had since College uh who is very
Lefty very liberal she's open-minded
though I mean she's not like one of
these people's just like I can't talk to
you she's buying up gold like nuts she
has been for a couple of years wow
and she has like a good job and money
and you know who else is buying lots of
goals she's also started uh China yeah
really China's opened a whole bunch of
these we buy Golds throughout the United
States she's also started planting her
own food she's like getting kind of
freaked out
not exactly totally normal because she's
my friend she's kind of weirdo but like
compared to me she's sort of normal
another thing is people don't realize
that like outside of the United States
if you go to Saudi Arabia if you're in
in the Middle East there are vending
machines that you can buy gold bars in
wow you know like vending machines
vending machines they'll be like whether
they're like tiny you know tenth of an
ounce or whatever ATM but uh well I mean
I don't know I I assume I don't know
what they're what they're like I've Got
Friends that look like yeah I've got
friends that have gone over and told me
they're like and my friend has bought
actual gold from the vending machines it
is normal to consider gold a store of
value outside of the US America we're so
used to you know just looking at dollars
the dollar exactly but other countries
and and other societies where the value
of currency sometimes fluctuates or has
gone crazy and stuff and also in the
Middle East they've always been very
interested in Tangerine assets and stuff
like that if I understand correctly so
it's not strange to be like yo I'm going
to get gold and another thing people
think when I buy gold it's like I'm
gonna buy gold and then I'm like oh I'm
out of the money it's when you buy gold
you're not out of the money yeah it's
like putting it into it's like putting
into a really safe Bank did diamonds
personally I don't like Jewels I don't
think diamonds have any value right like
haven't people stopped buying diamonds
because well they're manufactured now
yeah so it's like there's just no
I I mean I'm not telling anyone what
they should or should not buy personally
this is the language that has been
valuable over the years this is the
thing that uh you know I didn't learn
when you're living paycheck to paycheck
you are outside of this system when you
are making more money than you need per
paycheck all of a sudden the money you
spend never leaves
so like you start making more money and
you start building up a savings now
you've got a savings sitting your bank
account money doesn't leave let's say
you decide to buy something so you buy a
car car has value now you still retain
the value of your assets whereas for
most people they're renting they're
they're uh they have a lease on a car or
something like that if they do have one
or they're not they're using Uber all
their money is being sucked away from
them they can't build wealth and that's
of course the objective yes that you owe
nothing and you will be happy yeah but
also the cbdc where it's programmable
and they can just turn it off or they
can say if you don't spend it in 30 days
it disappears yup so that's stupid and
if they if they make if you get a cbdc
don't think you're going to be allowed
to buy gold like if you get once they
have more body armor exactly the EBT
card you can't buy beer with it exactly
they will be able to program and buy hot
food what you can't buy hot food yeah
yeah it can't be prepared yeah so you'll
you won't be able to buy anything that
has actual value they will not allow you
to take your cbdc they won't let you
build well exactly
and that is going to be built into the
system like it's not some it's not going
to be an option nowadays as long as
there's cash you can still go and buy
you know whether whether even if it's
just you know even if it's uh silver
coins dimes and and quarters and half
dollars from pre-1964. there though
that's where the silver that's when they
stopped using silver and coins in the
U.S
um those are still available you can get
them with dollars as soon as there's a
cbdc all that's on all that's done
that's off the table and just like you
said you're not going to be able to buy
armor you're not going to be able to buy
ammo you're not going to be able to buy
guns if they don't want you to buy guns
maybe you'll be able to buy certain guns
they'll have certain guns that have
probably some kind of micro stamping or
something like that but it's all all of
the the direction that we're heading in
is all about control it's all top down
control and you know I know there are
people that are watching this that are
like yeah we know we're on the same page
we've been listening this forever and
ever
but the average person starting to buy
gold means that people that are not
plugged into this type of world they're
not you know they're they're starting to
smell the bad smell of top down control
and it's something that people need to
pay attention to and go and go into that
point and then also what you were saying
at the beginning of the broadcast about
people need to get away from these hot
zones these danger zones
um I'm I'm seeing that and what you were
saying about your friend I'm seeing the
normies start to wake up I'm seeing them
people that I know who I never would
have thought would be tapped into this
sense of urgency that that a lot of us
have had for many years and that's why
we do what we do that's why you're here
in you know this part of the country
with your studio and not and where you
were before
um that's why you know you've moved
around I've moved around this sense of
urgency saying you know right now we
still have that ability to to relocate
to find that place that we feel like is
best for us
um to ride out the storm so to speak and
I'm seeing the normies are starting to
pick up on that too people that I know
does that mean that it's too late no I
don't think so I don't think it's too
late at all I think it's it's important
there's still time it's still there's
still time to like save the Republic oh
no I mean there's still time oh no no
the Republic's Dad yeah
like yeah yeah
I think the Republic will be uh what I
really want is a cow will win I think
we'll win or maybe like a sheep get all
of them men I can't get all of them so
one of the roosters escaped the other
day and so when I ride my bike up to the
studio and I'm coming in in the morning
I see this this dumb
little mother wandered around the yard
by himself and I'm like he'll be fine
he's a rooster whatever I go in and then
I'm in the studio and then I record my
first segment I go over the window and I
look and there's walking around
the yard and I'm like
so I went down and I walked over and I
opened the little little gate because
there's an outside portion inside and he
ran inside and then you know he wouldn't
do his chicken business but you know
these things I love chickens are
hilarious keep them away ridiculous oh
no wow
it's been 10 years so I didn't need that
visual though thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time